Este vídeo le ayudará a entender la
insuficiencia cardíaca y cómo
controlarla mire el video completo para
aprender a controlar la insuficiencia
cardíaca si le diagnosticaron
insuficiencia cardíaca es importante que
controle sus síntomas la insuficiencia
cardíaca también llamada insuficiencia
cardíaca congestiva o icc es una
enfermedad Crónica en la que el corazón
sigue funcionando pero no también como
debería el corazón no puede bombear
suficiente sangre y oxígeno para
satisfacer las necesidades de su cuerpo
se acumula un exceso de líquido en los
pulmones las piernas y otros tejidos del
cuerpo con el tiempo la insuficiencia
cardíaca debilita el corazón y puede
acortar su vida si no se la controla
como corresponde los síntomas de la
insuficiencia cardíaca incluyen
dificultad para respirar tos crónica o
sibilancias hinchazón de las piernas los
pies o el abdomen
aumento de peso
sensación de cansancio permanente
náuseas o falta de apetito
palpitaciones del corazón dificultad
para permanecer acostado debido a
sensaciones de asfixia y tener que
sentarse para respirar afortunadamente
usted puede ayudar a controlar sus
síntomas si sigue las instrucciones del
Médico
adopta un estilo de vida saludable para
el corazón y Presta atención a los
cambios en sus síntomas
seguir las instrucciones de su equipo de
atención de la salud es muy importante
para controlar los síntomas y prevenir
viajes innecesarios al hospital esto
incluye tomar su medicación exactamente
como lo prescribió su médico no deje de
tomar los medicamentos ni omita ninguna
dosis
tome nota de cualquier efecto secundario
e infórmeselo a su médico si el costo de
su medicación es un problema evalúe
otras opciones con su médico
no tome ninguna medicación o suplemento
de venta libre sin antes consultar a su
médico
solicite y cumpla siempre con todas sus
citas de seguimiento tanto para las
consultas médicas como para los exámenes
de laboratorio vacúnese contra la gripe
y la neumonía según lo indique su médico
controlar su insuficiencia cardíaca
también significa adoptar un estilo de
vida saludable es posible que deba
realizar los siguientes cambios límite
su consumo de sal y sodio a 2000
miligramos por día de la siguiente
manera no agregues sal al cocinar ni a
la comida en la mesa evite los alimentos
procesados y las comidas rápidas compare
las etiquetas de los alimentos y elija a
aquellos con menos contenido de sal y
sodio
siga una dieta saludable para el corazón
incluyendo alimentos con bajo contenido
de grasa y colesterol y alto contenido
en fibra lea las etiquetas para
verificar las cantidades de estos
ingredientes y también de otros por
ejemplo la harina de avena es un
alimento bajo en grasa y colesterol y
alto en fibra una dieta saludable para
el corazón le ayuda a mantener o lograr
una buena presión arterial y un buen
peso y a prevenir otras afecciones que
pueden estresar aún más su corazón
limita el consumo de alcohol pregúntele
a su médico si su afección le permite
incluir alcohol en su dieta controle su
ingesta de líquidos
el exceso de líquido hace que el corazón
trabaje más pregúntele a su médico Cuál
es la cantidad de líquido adecuada para
usted
no fume
la nicotina aumenta la frecuencia
cardíaca y la presión arterial al tiempo
que disminuye la cantidad de sangre rica
en oxígeno que llega a los tejidos del
cuerpo
manténgase físicamente activo la
actividad física periódica a través de
actividades diarias como la jardinería y
el trabajo doméstico puede hacer que se
sienta mejor otras buenas opciones de
actividad física con la aprobación de su
médico son caminar nadar y andar en
bicicleta al hacer ejercicio tenga
presentes estas precauciones descanse
según sea necesario deténgase se siente
dolor en el pecho o falta de aliento
mayor de la habitual y no haga actividad
física cuando las temperaturas sean muy
altas o muy bajas el médico también
puede prescribir un programa de
rehabilitación cardíaca que es una
combinación de ejercicio bajo
supervisión médica asesoramiento sobre
estilo de vida y educación
es importante que preste atención a los
cambios en sus síntomas y que sepa
cuándo pedir ayuda
el uso de los colores del semáforo verde
amarillo y rojo para evaluar Cómo se
siente puede ayudarle a tomar la acción
apropiada para controlar sus síntomas de
insuficiencia cardíaca el verde es su
meta y significa que sus síntomas están
bajo control
continúe siguiendo las indicaciones de
su médico y cumpla con todas las citas
médicas
diariamente para ver si su cuerpo
retiene líquidos
hágalo a la misma hora todos los días
antes de comer o beber y usa el mismo
tipo de ropa
registre y tome nota de cualquier cambio
en el peso
los síntomas que se encuentran en la
zona amarilla son señales de advertencia
llame a su médico inmediatamente sí gana
dos a tres o más libras en un día o 5
libras en una semana tiene mayor
dificultad para respirar
tiene dificultades para dormir debido a
la dificultad para respirar siente
persistentes latidos cardíacos rápidos o
irregulares tiene sensación de
desvanecimiento o de que se va a
desmayar los síntomas que se encuentran
en la Zona Roja son emergencias que
significan que necesita una evaluación
médica de inmediato Llame al 911 se
experimenta lo siguiente dolor en el
pecho que dura más de 15 minutos falta
de aliento grave y permanente
tos con espuma rosada y espesa
o desmayo
controlar los síntomas y seguir las
instrucciones de su médico puede
ayudarle a controlar la insuficiencia
cardíaca y reducir sus viajes al
hospital